seit dem mittelalter hat das deutsche
immer wieder wörter aus dem
französischen übernommen
deutsch hat also nicht nur viele wörter
aus dem englischen sondern auch aus dem
französischen und viele deutsch lernen
sind immer wieder überrascht plötzlich
französisch klingende wörter im
deutschen zu hören
bei uns ist heute giuditta woher kommst
du ich kam aus frankreich
judith ist nämlich eine französische
zuschauerin von easy german und
mittlerweile auch teil von unserem easy
friends team und wir zeigen euch heute
wörter die aus dem französischen in die
deutsche sprache übernommen wurden und
wir testen wie diese wörter heute
ausgesprochen werden und ob das wirklich
noch französisch ist los geht's ich habe
jetzt die 50 häufigsten wörter
ausgewählt und ich weiß selber nicht ob
wir die richtig französisch aussprechen
oder schon eingedeutscht haben es gibt
einige wörter die werden noch
französisch ausgesprochen und
geschrieben einige wörter werden schon
deutsch geschrieben aber noch ein
bisschen französisch ausgesprochen und
einige wahrscheinlich nicht mehr los
geht's abonnement
manche leute sagen auch abonnement
assessor qsa adresse aktuell aktuell
armee balance balance das ist das ist
gleich batterie patrick kunkel oder ein
bisschen deutschland ausgesprochen
bonbon branche branche budget büro büro
kaffee das war einfach chance chance wir
haben dass er am ende auch aus ihrer
chance das gibt es bei vielen worten
champagner dass sie existiert nicht es
klingt aber französisch vielleicht schon
bald ein klick klick
guck mal besprechen wir das nicht aber
bei clique schwierig nur das okay das
nächste creme oder creme crème großer
das ist einfach die avu sicherlich
delegation delegation dusche durch egal
[Musik]
engagiert und etage etat europa super
das ist tatsächlich ein wort was nun in
deutschen häufig benutzt was aber wenige
deutsche schreiben können weil es sehr
französisch geschrieben wird gage genial
giraffe in shiraz gruppe an group gruppe
hotel ingenieur an nati ni.com mal so
ein schwieriges wort haben wir aus dem
französischen genommen und heute haben
wir noch witzige deutsche hitze dazu
nämlich dem ingenieur ist nichts zu
schwör
es ist ein deutscher wortwitz das nicht
so schwer ist michael reim schwer an
ingenieur service dem ingenieur ist
nichts zu schwör journalist journalist
kapitän und hätte ich denn das klavier
und klar dass komplett gedreht
[Musik]
das ist interessant meine theorie ist
umso länger das wort in der deutschen
sprache ist desto deutscher ist es wenn
einige worte sind wahrscheinlich schon
ein paar hundert jahre in der deutschen
sprache und wir wissen gar nicht mehr
dass die französisch sind
das ist meine theorie krawatte krawatte
menü armenisch niveau niveau 19
am net internet orange in orange paket
der pilot ab jetzt das pissoir was ist
eigentlich so es ist eine toilette für
männer ist ja okay dann denken wir nur
dass das französisch ist es war gomez
schritt ja das weiß müssen wir auch die
meisten deutschen nicht mehr dass das
wort pommes aus französisch kommt und
eigentlich ausgesprochen wird
portemonnaie tochter mini das ist ein
interessantes wort das würde vor kurzem
geändert wir haben das sehr sehr lange
französisch geschrieben
aber weil viele deutsche nicht das
richtig schreiben können auf französisch
ist ja auch kompliziert gibt es jetzt
eine neue rechtschreibung nämlich die
deutsche rechtschreibung mit mmg findest
du das witzig als sehr witzig es gibt
glaube ich viele wörter die nach einiger
zeit angepasst werden manche aber nicht
hotspot rich regime arien regisseur mal
richtig der reportage über das resümee
gute saison im sommer soße - der
deutsche schreibt manchmal auch so mit ß
und service jährlich szene1 at toilette
rituals das glaube ich mein
lieblingswort die toilette
zuletzt dankeschön zuletzt das damit
gemacht hast
danke und ihr könnt jetzt auch weiter
deutsch lernen und zwar nicht nur
französische worte aber ihr könnt die
deutsche aussprache lernen indem ihr
unsere app sieht lang ausprobiert dort
findet ihr nämlich auch viele sätze wo
kein vokabeltrainer und ihr könnt dabei
immer eure aussprache trainieren indem
ihr selber setzte wiederholt und eure
eigene aussprache evaluiert und dadurch
verbessert ihr eure aussprache probiert
das mal aus hier findet ihr einen link
und dann seht ihr demnächst auch easy
french und zwar auf unserem easy
languages kanal hier findet ihr einen
link zur letzten episode mit judith dort
hat sie nämlich das französische r
vorgestellt danke dir nämlich auch die
französische aussprache lernen
bis bald